you think what you don't you don't think
most guys have no I I agree I just feel
like
you can
for example you can have a girl that
you're like that's your gun and you can
just
you can be with anybody like it doesn't
matter with I mean that's the point that
I'm making like yeah I agree with you
okay yeah so I'm just saying like yeah
but it don't matter it can be she can be
old young
thickens like any it don't matter like
it's just for that moment yeah because I
think when a guy sees a girl that he
finds attractive without even knowing
her name if she was like you're gonna
come to this coming right now nine times
out of ten he's gonna say he'd be like
yeah but when a girl sees a guy that's
attractive even if she's like oh he's
really hot a lot of the time and correct
me if I'm wrong ladies but I feel like a
lot of time you still be like even
though I would have sex with you I
hardly still want to know if you're a
decent person before I do it's more like
I don't want to catch anything
like I'm not trying to run bad STD and
you can't have kids so I'm not trying to
yeah please have please please have
protected sex yeah but you can so
there's still [ __ ] you can catch with
protected sex yeah sure but but me from
and I just feel like if a guy was coming
up to me and asking them like how many I
can't be the first
I mean
let's put this into context of real life
cat how many times have women come up to
you and gone do you want to come with me
into this back alley like anyone has
that ever happened to any of you guys
like no but really openly you've never
had a conversation and they've
propositioned you straight off the bat
has that ever happened to any of you
guys not like the first thing she said
but within like a couple of minutes only
once yeah
the one I've got was
um they'll say but very in subtle ways I
remember one time yeah the girl was like
oh do you want to come back for cuddles
[Music]
yeah so yeah it'd be very so it won't be
like guys it's always trying to be yeah
yeah and I think guys the way guys
approach to go in that manner is
different to how a woman approaches a
guy in a manner if a girl approaches a
guy in the same way sometimes he can put
you off and be like that that was a bit
too easy like
there was nothing for me to work with
like it was just
take it you know
I asked that because from a female
perspective my concern is more the
safety of the fact that I don't know who
you are and it's less about that's true
it's it's less about the fact you've
propositioned me openly for sex and more
about the fact you could hurt me
physically yeah yeah I don't I don't
know you and also I think it's another
thing of intimacy right so much of sex
for me is intimacy I I couldn't sleep
with someone I'd never even had a
conversation with who I knew I didn't
click with because how can I be
vulnerable with this person first of all
like the best sex I've ever had has been
with someone I've either been in love
with or I've been able at least to be
intimate with but you know I already
know them we already know we've probably
already had I'm a very open person in
case you couldn't tell
um so I'm able to have a conversation
with the person I'm about to sleep with
or I am sleeping with about what I like
what I enjoy and if someone propositions
you straight off the bat yeah yeah okay
like the chances of it being good are
quite slim because they don't know who
you are they don't know what you like
they don't know what you enjoy you've
not had any conversation about consent
so I I think that's also I think that's
another thing guys what about you with
only fans would you date a girl with
only fans
no seriously no not seriously no no
I wouldn't even though even though you
could understand getting on it
even though you said you wanted but I
don't think there's a any guy that would
consider himself like a proper man that
would wife
yeah the old wife
um a girl that's on only fans like that
see I feel like you have something to
see here give her the mic give the god
of mine Jesus
that's strong words
um no just more this thing about uh what
What's what is a proper man what someone
who doesn't uh yeah I guess to do with
things it's him man with standards
and I think it's like important to like
have standards and I always tell men
when they can't have standards
I think it's important to have standards
but I think that's I don't think again
someone's numbers is a reflection of
their standards or what someone does
foreign but there's there's research
that shows that more the more Partners
you like the woman has the less likely
she will be happy in the marriage and
the like the there's higher rates of
depression like there's a lot of things
that are negative that are linked to the
more people you sleep with so so so can
like how is it bad for a guy to say I
don't want to deal with that because
that's just a standard he has okay the
thing I would challenge with that how
big are these studies and also you
cannot isolate these all of these people
who have not had the same life
experiences so you cannot isolate just
the amount of people they've slept with
the the control variables are slim but
don't I agree with you like that's
that's where their discernment comes in
but like I don't think there's anything
wrong with the guy saying like like that
he wouldn't date someone that's on oh I
I yeah we we've had this conversation as
well I said again I completely I can't
make you sleep with anything I can't
make you go yeah absolutely what if you
had a son or a brother like you you
really would encourage them to like date
someone with an audience it's not even a
thing of encouragement I'm neutral I
would encourage you to not be prejudiced
I would encourage you to view someone
for who they are as a person and I think
what you do for a job and who you've
slept with is completely irrelevant I
think it's about who so what if he's a
criminal the guy so if a guy if a guy's
a a criminal and he has a past of like
yeah sex offenses like you don't think
your actions show who you are oh and
what kind of person again that's not to
do with the fact that he slept with
women that's to do with the way again
like that's I think that's a complete
that's well that's so left but I think
but I think no but it it does because a
girl that slept with more men like I
think the the issue is ensuring
paternity they're worried that when in
the relationship she's going to do the
same thing because that's her habits the
last couple years the same way that like
if a guy a girl's looking at a guy and
he's cheated in every single
relationship he's been in like that's
your habit that's what you do that's who
you are as a person okay but I think
sleeping with lots of people doesn't
equate you being a cheater I think so
when when you say about a guy can't
guarantee paternity okay but if she's
someone who slept with a lot of people
but monogamously then the trend is she
slept with a lot of people monogamously
so it's like okay she's only sleeping
with you monogamously we're talking
about once oh so so that's what we're
talking about like he said he like his
he said that he like a proper
but man wouldn't date a girl with an old
should I should I tell you what I think
it is correct me if I'm wrong right is
that I think
the thing that I think sometimes girls
don't understand about men is that
respect is very important
and respect amongst other men especially
men that you consider your peers who you
value men you look up to men who look up
to you is very important
and if you're a guy and you have
committed and invested yourself
in the good thing is there are plenty of
women who may have great qualities as
the girl who has no hands but they don't
have enough does that make sense so I
think if you as a man have choose have
chosen to commit and invest yourself in
a woman that you feel doesn't give great
respect to you because your partner is a
reflection of you who you choose is a
reflection of you
then that does play a part in him
thinking okay is this somebody who I
want to represent me to the world does
that make sense so it I think you know
like Chris you said you're gonna name
right yeah right and you're Nigerian
yeah you sound Nigerian so respect in
our culture is huge